[Music]
well we've teased you sufficiently with
news of our upcoming movie and now we
can officially announce here on life is
short
there's a release date
christian
september 17th yep 2021. so enjoy the
summer and then know that usually uh as
the summer winds down there was always a
time where it was like there was a
little bit of
uh melancholy that set in would you say
you know because you got a course
school's going coming back but now uh if
you are in school and if if that
melancholy sets in maybe you can uh use
this news to that's so arrogant i know
it's the most arrogant
mitigate the effects of the doldrums
late summer well if you haven't heard us
blabbing about our movie um up to this
point it's called lady the manor oh yeah
that's that's a good point i i should i
should know this also because we'll be
doing a lot of promotion for it
uh as the months as you know we approach
september so i should remember to
actually say the name of the movie yes
uh and for now we should get into the
podcast that's true because that's what
we're here for i know we don't want to
take up time from the podcast talking
about our movie lady the man or two
uh here we go september 17th what did i
say i'm repeating it oh okay because it
bears repeating because lady of the
manor is coming out september 17th being
released by lionsgate yes lions thanks
to everyone at lionsgate2 and thanks to
everyone wondering for letting us do
this podcast and here it is
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host and co-director of lady of
manor justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
lady of the manor what did i say ladies
and manor
okay
and uh with me as always is mike
somewhat critical and
of my speech of my co-director
co-director i was going to get to that
uh chris christian line christian law
christian long is a co-director
co-writer uh of lady of the manor but
right now we're doing a podcast that has
nothing to do with the lady the manner
well that's not entirely true that's
that's right because it'll be seen by by
the way you can see it all over the
world we don't know exactly the platform
but it'll be one of those streams i
think it's coming out in some theaters
uh once people get back in there the
movie is um a comedy
and it's stars
it stars melanie linsky and judy greer
it's a buddy comedy and me and justin
long and ryan phillippe and patrick
duffy louis guzman uh good cast good
good
uh good cast and it's a really fun kind
of uh if you grew up on we grew up on
like the 80s buddy comedies like what
about bob and planes trains and
automobiles movies like that we were
really inspired by so if you like those
movies hopefully
that's also very arrogant i was gonna
say if you like those movies hopefully
you'll like this it's in the same vein
yeah
yeah it's in the same ballpark i think
it's funny i think it's really i i i'm
proud of it me too you're bothered to be
proud of the movie you've directed
well you know it and like we said
september 17th you can see it all over
the world if you live in america if you
live in um canada yep
senegal
uh you know mozambique indonesia jakarta
indonesia uh or anywhere in
timor uh or france anywhere in france uh
leon
nice you're just bragging terrorist
cities you know in france paris
oh
see what i do
i smell a segway see speaking of paris
uh our guest today
happens to be named paris
she also is a lady who may have lived in
a manner at some point that might have
been a better yeah
ah man you said you beat me in the
segway off
um wouldn't that be i just imagined us
on segways having a race have you ever
i've been honest now i have you have
it's really fun where'd you do that on a
tour uh no i did it in um orange county
somewhere
over yeah july 4th weekend about 13
years ago i did it the same day when you
got uh
kidnapped and jumped out of that car
yeah that's what you were doing yeah i'm
picturing like a montage to like
something tells me i'm into something
like you in a cheesy montage of having
fun in orange county yeah we have very
different days holy [ __ ] yeah cause i
remember july 2nd 2008 it was yeah july
4th weekend 13 years ago i was right oh
my god
yeah because i remember getting a
voicemail from you briefly explaining
what had just happened god that must
have been a crazy message again it was a
crazy day i'm trying to think of another
way to introduce person so lady the
manor oh yeah well she and you're right
she probably did live in a manner
our guest but she might still live in
america i'm sure she's or manners
yeah i'm sure she is i think her pets
live in manors i think that's how they
do wealthy she is she grew up um the
heir to the hilton the hotel chain she
was she's an heiress she's our first
heiress i think i think so i was just
wondering if eris is pejorative not
pejorative but if diminishes like you
shouldn't be gender specific about that
stuff anymore oh
she's an hair fine yeah or maybe she's
nervous i don't know she everyone knows
her i don't think heiress is would care
would carris
um i don't think she'd care about that i
she's harrison she is an heiress it
feels weird to introduce her only
because
everyone knows i know it feels
unnecessary she's got to be one of my
most popular guests
if not the most because i would say
she's one of the most famous people on
the planet well that's the thing it's
like and i asked her about this we get
into it you'll hear um but i was curious
about how she sees herself as a pop
culture figure you know how she would
describe herself because you're right
everybody knows her and and to call her
just an heir or an heiress uh it seems
to kind of diminish all the she does a
lot of things
um and she's i don't know i before i saw
this documentary that i would recommend
to everybody it's called this is paris i
think it's on netflix
or hulu it's really good it's about um
her this trauma that she went through as
a as i don't want to say student but as
a member of this like
disciplinary
school this like really abusive academy
that she and a lot of kids go to or sent
to by their parents um she had you know
she had problems and and her parents i
guess were desperate to get her help uh
but this place ended up being really
abusive she talks about it but it's just
to give you some context for for the
interview because we most of it is i
think a lot of it is about that that
documentary um so if if you can't don't
have time to watch the whole thing maybe
just do a brief um internet check of uh
you know her activism in regards to that
yeah because it's really interesting and
something that i had no frame of
reference for until i saw the
documentary and
before then i knew her the way probably
most people do is just a figure in pop
culture and we did spend some time with
her right that's true over the course of
a summer that's true i would say we saw
her three or four times that summer
i wondered if she remembered
oh
i don't know well i remember at that
summer it got to the point where
she when she'd see us
at her one of her parties she'd be like
oh hey guys that's true we became
familiar that's true we were
yes i don't know if we roast the level
of acquaintance yeah we were close
that's true i don't think we were
acquaintance level but i remember her
having much like andy warhol we talk
about that as an influence she had
framed like
paintings of herself everywhere i
remember being struck by that and all
the animals that she had she had really
exotic strange animals one in particular
i remember she had this
vine snake like a ribbon snake this
green beautiful snake
and i remember getting really nervous
about how
she was handling it only because it was
a part not that she was handling it but
that it was out of its cage in a party
situation and she seemed
you know like she knew what she was
doing with it she was taking care of it
i remember that you were like uh that's
very delicate yeah
um i felt a little nerdy for that moment
but um yeah she's a friend oh the
animals yes well let's let's hear let's
hear from her okay so here it is uh
friend of the animals and uh all
all-around famous person and hopefully
future fan of lady of the manor which
comes out september 17th that's right
good
nice segue here she is paris hilton
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again shaboom and nobody
will meet again
[Music]
the documentary is incredible uh this is
paris and
what what motivated you to do that why
did you want to expose yourself in that
way
as opposed to
this persona you had created what was it
about that filmmaker that moment in your
life where you felt like now's the time
to kind of
really show people who i am
the original premise of the film was not
that at all i was doing the film because
i felt that for so long people had
misunderstood me
i just been underestimated and i was
just sick of this blonde stereotype of
the character that i created from simple
life and i just felt like i accomplished
so much and i really wanted to showcase
that but then i just became so
incredibly close with the director after
you know shooting a year together that i
opened up to her in ways i never had
before
so the plan was never to even talk about
so this is alexander the movie's amazing
alexandra dean
the way she's she puts it together it's
really well done um
and at the end of it i mean you
i'm not telling you you know you've
exposed you expose a lot about your
trauma and
a struggle that i had no idea about i
you know if anybody had ever told me
that you had struggled in this way until
i witnessed that documentary and
what was it about alexandra what was it
about the the journey that you took with
her
that you felt emboldened to open up like
that that you felt like okay i i wanna
i wanna uncover this trauma and talk
about it
well this was around seven months into
shooting and we were in korea i was
just emotionally and physically
exhausted just on this press tour or i'm
no sleep
just tired and that's when i kind of
opened up to her about my nightmares and
she was like very curious and i was like
but don't put it in the movie
she's like well you know that's
something important like what happened i
was like i don't want it in the movie
the basement i told her you know i went
to these schools and they were very
abusive but
i made a promise to myself when i got
out of there that i would never discuss
this with anyone not even my family my
friends and just pretend it never
happened because it was just so
traumatic to think about sorry sorry rob
what was it why it was just that it was
just because it was so you didn't want
to relive it i mean even in the movie
when you discuss it when you meet with
the other survivors
you seem different you seem raw and
affected and it's like it's dredging
stuff up um was that the same reason why
you didn't want to
ever talk about it after you got out
it was just something that was so
horrible to even think about it that i
just felt like if i buried it and just
never thought about it
and i thought people would judge me
because in these places they make the
kids feel very ashamed like it's their
fault and
you're a young girl like you don't
it's hard to even think that that could
happen but it does so it was just very
difficult to speak about and i didn't
want people knowing that part of my life
i bet especially in the life that you
were living you obviously people know
that you you lived up until that point
you lived in a privileged home and but
you describe the moment where people men
grown men take you out of bed i mean
it sounds like it was out of a movie you
describe it as feeling like it was out
of a movie grown men kidnap you really
and
um
when you confronted your mom about that
which you do at the end of the movie
was she like totally shocked by it which
was was she like
um
at all did she feel guilty how did that
resolve itself um yeah like you were
saying it was like something out of the
movie taken it was
terrifying to be taken out of my bed
like that by these men and
my mom
and my dad feel extremely guilty but
they had no idea she was in complete
shock when i told her because she
didn't think the premise of the movie
had anything to do with that either
so you know when the director was asking
her questions about it she was
blindsided so it was very difficult for
her to hear because it was the first
time she's ever heard it before and it's
on camera so she's probably like oh [ __ ]
i
did she have a moment afterwards where
she was like
i don't
i don't know if i want to be a part of
this i don't know if i want to do this
publicly
she
was upset just because she feels like
the whole movie focused a lot of that on
that and
doesn't want to be judged because of
something that happened a long time ago
manipulate the families and
they just think that they're sending
their kid to a normal boarding school
like in your wildest dreams can you
imagine sending your child somewhere in
that happening like it's just it is and
and when you were there were there any i
mean obviously you made you talk about
all the attempts you made to escape the
other places but weren't they afraid
that these kids are going to go back to
their parents and
and just and describe the abuse i mean
wasn't there how did they get away with
that they got away with it just by lying
to the parents saying your kid's gonna
belate you
and any time like myself or any of the
other kids would try to say something on
the phone with our parents or write a
letter we would get just screamed at
punished hit
so you were kind of like beaten in to
think like to not speaking about it and
they said when you get out of here no
one will ever believe you so
don't even try so a lot of people don't
talk about it ever again
i bet like you said they're adults these
are adults these are these are authority
figures who you grow up trusting um
i can't imagine what that did to you and
yet you describe what it did to you and
it's it's it's really fascinating that
you when you got out you said
you were going to do everything in your
power to be successful so that your
parents could never control you again
and so you created this kind of uh
well you described as a brand and i'm
fascinated by your two different voices
where where did that voice where did
that character
of paris hilton come from
do you know can you point to any like
specific influence like oh was marilyn
monroe or it was so and so
marilyn monroe mixed with like if barbie
could speak
i uh-huh just so depressed that i like
would just think of like what i was
going to do when i got out of there and
i was creating this other person and i
just i wanted to live fantasy barbie
life so i wouldn't have to ever think
about all that
so you were thinking of that when you
were locked up when you were in this uh
huh
and and and so then it became like the
new york party scene and it became
paparazzi and all the things that people
know but um
and i i kept thinking about your
grandmother how your grandmother must
have had i just um she seemed like a
very strong influence in your life and
she seemed like somebody who
fetishized as my grandmother did who
unfortunately just passed away but she i
was very close with her
she fetishized these like glamorous
hollywood
icons you know um
was that a part of it was it was it like
i want to i want to have my
grandmother's respect and i want to be
seen in a certain way
uh i think maybe that has something to
do with that i always wanted to make her
proud and ever since i was a baby she
would call me marilyn monroe and grace
kelly bardot and all of these amazing
icons so i think i kind of
you know grew up wanting to be that
but and yet you naturally as a kid
correct me if i'm wrong seemed so
different than that i mean you seemed
like
your nikki describes you as a tomboy and
every shot of you in these home videos
that you're playing with little
creatures and anytime i've been around
you you've been you've had creatures
around you've had little animals uh and
people might think like oh little
chihuahuas and stuff but no i've seen
you with
i remember one time being at your house
you had a snake you had a little
like a ribbon like a green vine snake uh
a menagerie
what
what what derailed that paris hilton
like and where how does where is she now
like where is that person
well i'm still here i'm still
animals i still have my menagerie i've
loved animals my whole life
um and now i'm just
i'm an adult so i can actually process
all i've been through and see why i am
the way i am like that's why i'm so
grateful to alexander dean
pulling that out of me in this movie
because it was the most healing and a
therapeutic experience of my life and
now i'm free like i can be myself and
it's just such an amazing feeling i feel
so empowered
i bet
prior to that um
do you think that contributed to the
lack of sleep and and describe to people
that anxiety like the anxiety that comes
with having these two
almost two very drastically different
personas like like the you that i feel
like i'm talking to now
who literally sounds different than the
person that a lot of people think they
might know what is that anxiety like how
does that feel to live with that
it was
traumatizing just every single night
since i was 16 i had that same nightmare
of them
coming into my room grabbing me out of
the bed like thinking i'm gonna be
killed or raped it was just like
terrifying and then that happened
actually a couple times the first time i
had no idea what was happening but the
other times i looked new but it was just
terrifying every time so
just nightmares severe for so long until
i did the documentary and talked about
it so i think really it got rid of those
nightmares for some reason they're gone
i mean you sleep okay
oh great dreams now
that's so good to hear it really is
because my
my heart just broke for you watching
this thing i wanted to
hug you you know i wanted to
yeah it's it's uh really compelling and
your sister is funny like every feeling
i had about
any sort of compassionate response i had
about you your sister then
would would mirror you know she would
say um
she seems like somebody who really
has i'm sure you both looked out for
each other but but she seems like a
really good guy
to have um so blessed to have her
yeah um when she says things like she's
one of those moments was when she says
um i was i found myself thinking why
don't you just
stop or slow down or like unplug for a
minute you know why don't you just and
she said the same thing um
why don't you why why don't you
chill out a little bit
i think before i just
because of what i've been through i just
wanted to kind of
not think about it so i would keep
myself so busy that there was no chance
to ever think about bad memories
and i wasn't really fulfilled in my
personal life because i just was single
i wasn't happy just i just felt alone
like no one understood me
and now i'm an amazing relationship so i
finally can relax and chill and i
because of the pandemic but um right
yeah we're all chilling
yeah that's really great and you talk
about your trust issues and and um i
found myself really relating to a lot of
that uh
how do you now try i mean
what where do you stand when it comes to
that now are you
do you feel healthier
trust wise do you test people do you
find yourself like who can i really
trust how do you test people it's hard
it's very hard in this town to trust
friends like thank god yeah a
relationship where i finally trust the
person but
friends it's it's sometimes hard
especially la is just a very fake town
there's a lot of users and people who
just don't have good intentions so i
will do some tests like i'll tell them
like like some weird rumor and then if
it ends up fixed i'm like okay
yeah weed it out
and check yeah um
but now you're in a good relationship
that's really good to hear because
it also that documentary that i mean
that guy that moment at the festival
it was like uh it's another moment i was
like wanted to
i mean i wanted to do something to that
guy he was being i mean
felt so abusive um
and so i'm glad that you're not in that
relationship anymore i was not a
relationship by the way i like knew that
person for like a week
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
and he see you had described to nicki
like the people that you were
uh
you had been dating or you and you
wanted to avoid they were like these
i forget like kind of neutered men yes
men type guys who just kind of went
along
for the ride um
are you now with somebody who you feel
like
you know has can can kind of give it
back a little bit it's more balanced
definitely um what's exactly what nikki
described in the film he said you need
to find your
on the respect and now i finally got my
equal he doesn't need anything for me he
doesn't care about being famous he has
his own
everything he's very fast
so great an amazing feeling to finally
have someone on my level
good uh paris that's um
really nice to hear uh
you um and you in the documentary you
see
you with her kids with nikki's kids and
um i kept thinking about the word love
as it relates to you because you use
that word a lot uh
you've made it famous you've made
expressions out of love like
loves this or what is it
he loves it
yes loves it
loves it i love you i love i had an
agent once who would say um okay i love
you and he said it in such a like
without any passion you know
but i it forced me to be like i love you
too but love that's such a sacred word
to me that um
did you find that word what is your
relationship like with that word i guess
like
when you say it to
did it lose some of its power because
you had just been
you know it had it become diluted that
word to you
yeah before i think i just never even
knew what love was because of yeah
things so
and just in past relationships just
being traumatized even after i got out
of the schools so
that word just totally lost all meaning
to me until now so um
it's good to finally know what it feels
like for real
uh when do just getting back to the two
voices when do you slip and when do you
use that other
that paris persona for it they're kind
of uh higher it's higher it's much
higher um
and um people are very surprised when
they hear it because they're like oh i
thought you only said that's hot
that's amazing
yeah it's like it's it's high yeah
you slip um it's weird it'll just come
out a little bit sometimes when i'm
either very shy or i'm trying to be
funny
or i'm purposely doing it as a joke but
um
well you meet i mean they show this too
but i've
you see you meeting all of these people
the [ __ ]
press that you do is crazy and uh
and you're very good about it i mean you
you take time with people and you're
and they are they
and i guess for the most part they're
satisfied with just uh
with that with a selfie with it loves it
or whatever
yeah did they ever
has a fan or somebody like that ever
stopped you in your tracks have they
ever been like
hey
trying to talk to you on a deeper level
and it's thrown you
have they ever jarred you lose from that
persona i guess yeah i actually have a
very close relationship they call
themselves the little hiltons and oh
yeah i've like invited them to like stay
with me we like i've flown them out
certain places like i'm actually really
good friends with my fans so we do have
real conversations and i'll talk with my
real voice and
oh wow it's that that does i thought
that too doesn't that cons
ah this might be hard to answer but
doesn't that concern you like if you get
too close to
i wish they called themselves the hilton
heads i feel like it'd be a better
hilton heads i have but whatever that's
for um does it concern you that like
what if
one of them
it's just such an
imbalance the power dynamic is so
off it seems with something like that
that what if someone if what if one of
them
got a little too
clingy or something they're always very
sweet there is some that are like insane
like guys like trying to like ask me to
marry them or showing up at my house or
people coming with knives like scary
things happen as well but the one
they're like my crew are normal and like
really sweet
like unconditional love
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wundery app
[Music]
[Music]
you talk about the the sex tape the
paris um you say if that happened today
it'd be a different story
i remember the the late night letterman
they show clips of those joking about it
and um
you say if that happened today it'd be a
different story but they made me the bad
person
how do you how does it feel now to like
look back at that time um because as an
outsider as just an observer
again my heart breaks for you that you
had to
go through that and and i think i think
everyone's lens is changing now um but
that guy seems like
such a scumbag the fact that he was
never
prosecuted is crazy um
what do you think would have happened
today like how do you think times have
changed um
in terms of stuff like that it's just a
whole new world
yeah going through that was the most
painful experience ever to be publicly
humiliated like that and
you know for the rest of my life people
are going to judge me based on one night
listen i trusted and um that just breaks
my heart and now today if that happened
that would
it would be a completely different story
like back then they would always kind of
villainize the woman and everything and
now it doesn't happen anymore because
people realize just how wrong it is
yeah and what an abuse of power it was
that this guy um forget that he was
older but he happened to have been older
and like he said it's this one and i
could and then i couldn't help think
like you're coming out of this
experience at provo where already your
trust issues are like i mean it must
have been shaken your parents are the
ones that did this to you and so now you
you find love or whatever with this guy
and he
i can't imagine
how much work that then requires to to
regain
um
to regain trust in in people and anyone
um you must have had to go on quite a
journey to
to heal that um and are you still on
that journey what does that look like
that's something that will haunt me for
the rest of my life
it's just
it's hard to even trust many people
because of that incident and everything
else that happened and um
i think that's something that i will
forever be
mortified by and hurt by
i i bet well i i am
so sorry uh uh and i'm sorry that i was
one of the people that didn't really
understand how hurtful something like
that must have been
what is you know because i was one of
most people who know who you are um
what does that feel like to to know that
people
have made these have these preconceived
notions about you have made these
judgments about you
um
how do you reconcile that is that does
that is that at the source of anxiety
and is that something that you set out
to change with this documentary and with
all the things you're doing we'll get to
them in a second um i feel like i've
been through so much in life i just have
such a tough skin that nothing really
bothers me
if i tried to think about all the people
with misconceptions and what they
thought of me i would go crazy so don't
think about it
and
the reason i really wanted to do it
because i just feel like all these you
know i'm a role model to young girls and
i didn't want them growing up thinking
it's okay to like play stupid like it's
it's sexy smart it's sexy to be in
control of your life and
i don't know i just wanted to show who i
really was since i have little girls
looking up to me and i don't i don't
know i just wasn't happy with the way i
was being portrayed this
was
yeah
yeah that makes sense i um
and so what do you do with all of that
stuff this simple life stuff they show
clips of the simple life where you were
you were so smart that you were like
one step ahead of you were playing a
character i mean you were it it looks
like that to me now
um
but what what do you
how do you think about that stuff that
that that stuff in your past that that
caricature
of this this marilyn monroe type
character i'm proud of it because you
know that reality show the simple life
was the first of its kind and now is
you know
really inspired a whole new genre of
celebrity and people still love it and
it's just timeless and iconic and i am
very proud and now people understand
that i was playing a character so
i love that people know now that i was
actually in on the job
uh-huh yeah i bet um you you say that
everybody says on the original
influencer and sometimes i think i
helped create a monster
um
do you ever think about i mean i i know
i already asked you this but i i
struggle with this do you ever think
about
just unplugging for a little bit
you you work so much you travel so much
you're
you talk about how much time how much
influencing you do social media stuff
do you ever think uh would you be happy
if you were to stop doing that for a
little bit i have to do it just because
all of my brands and my product lines
right you
that's your goal you say your goal is to
have a billion dollars that's not my
goal anymore because
oh okay
and um i just i think again i was just
so concerned with like because i didn't
have my personal life that i wasn't
happy with so i was just focusing on all
of these materialistic things that
really don't matter in life
well then this might answer this
question uh alexandra dean says at the
very end she says um
you know you can't do this forever
uh after your resolution with your
mother
she says can you and your brand have a
divorce now
and i was wondering that i'm i'm curious
about that you say you said something
very funny you said well it'd be a
really expensive divorce
um
but but i don't know i i won do you ever
do you think about that more uh if you
could part ways with that with that
brand
i think it's just
part of me and i think that people you
know have different layers to them and
that was just a part of my life and now
i'm
moving on to the next phase of my life
which is um
you know finally being an adult and um
being a real person so
you know i think that will be there in
the background
i related to that too paris you said um
there is something about getting to live
i've been an actor for a long time it's
it's kept me in the state of um
a certain type of adolescence
uh and and you say that too you say
you you you've never wanted to get
married because you that you feel like
that would force you to grow up i
related to that you post
deep down you felt trapped and um
is that has that changed too do you
still feel like marriage means growing
up and and if so are you a little less
afraid to to grow up
i was saying that before because i
thought that i would never find a man
that i could trust so
yeah i was like it's not even worth it
because he's going to end up hurting me
so why
but now i'm excited for that next
studies in my life like i can't wait to
oh this is great
oh that's correct it keeps coming back
to this this is i'm glad you have this
in your life now um
you
you uh you've done so many things in
entertainment uh your model actor
musician dj i don't realize you did
you talk about how there was that one
shot of that guy who snuck in and so a
lot of people didn't think you were
djing yourself but um
he literally turned up the volume for
one because he didn't have the whole
main volume on he only had the dj booth
so i thought music was playing
everywhere and then all of a sudden he
just came up to touch the main volume so
it would go around the whole arena and
that one one second that one picture
went everywhere and everyone was like oh
yeah he was there the whole time what
does that feel like weren't you tempted
to just respond to everybody or put
something out and say yeah [ __ ] you no i
explain what you just explained to me
how do you
how do you hold yourself back from that
i was so pissed because i
literally was for every day for six
hours a day for over a year practicing
learning everything there was to learn
because it's very technical when you dj
so i had to learn everything about it
all the different systems and then for
that to happen and then all my hard work
he just
but that gave me the drive to just try
even harder and i ended up getting you
know
residencies in ibiza and vegas and miami
and just all of these places and
becoming the number one female dj in the
world so i think that just really gave
me the drive to
drive
yeah for sure um
paris if an alien came down to earth
and they ran into you
and they wanted to understand who you
are and and what you do for a living
uh what would you tell them because i'm
thinking about all those things that you
did and i just want to try to how would
you distill it
for an alien well i'm an alien too so i
would say i'm one of you
okay well it's nice to meet you
i would say that i'm
an aquarian animal loving
boss
artist
okay uh so am i um if you could pick one
of those jobs though like if you had to
if you was just like hey i'm justin i
have a podcast oh i'm tom brady i'm a
football not to compare myself to tom
brady but if you were just like you had
one sentence to say that what what job
of those jobs would you pick to to
describe yourself like what do you
identify most with being an entrepreneur
that's another thing i gleaned from that
documentary it's incredible how hard you
work were you were you a big fan of andy
warhol i'm seeing a lot of like warhol
influences and post-modern type
yes obsessed i love we're all and i mom
was actually friends with him and he
used to come to after parties with the
waldorf and when i was like two years
old i would like to sit on his lap and
draw and he would look at me and tell my
mom like this girl's going to be a star
one day
oh my oh my god it's funny because your
mom seems so
conservative in a lot of ways i mean she
seems really nice she seems like a good
person but she seems
so conservative and like and then once
you started partying
it's
wasn't there a part of you that was like
hey you introduced me to
andy warhol
too
what'd you expect my mom had me so young
she was 19. so by the time
oh my god yeah i didn't know that um
uh if you weren't paris a known person
and yet have a job outside of the
limelight
i think i know the answer to this but
but what would it be and i have a guess
i would
probably a veterinarian because i love
animals yeah that's my guess what's your
favorite kind of animal dogs i remember
being at your house
which pets do you remember
uh they were mostly chihuahuas i
remember um did you have a chinchilla
you had some exotic
i feel like a chicken
the king chill the monkey i would have
remembered a monkey
you had a little monkey a pikachu
and a bush baby another type of monkey
yes you had a bush baby with the big
eyes yes
holy [ __ ]
how does one get a bush baby in las
vegas there's this exotic pet store
called kingdom 2000 you're like
josephine exotic
you uh
you describe yourself as a real homebody
i know you spent people might be
surprised to learn that but um
how do you take care of all those things
i can barely take care of a
a couple i have some turtles
i have a handful of turtles
yeah i love taking care of them but i
also have a team of people one of the
people who works jokes and calls herself
a zookeeper
oh yes
and are they where are they are they all
in one room all your your bush babies
and chihuahuas and
i have like different areas like i have
like a doggy mansion for the puppies
it's really cool and then
there's like kind of like these areas
and then my other animals the monkeys
because i was traveling so much i sent
them to my ranch so they're
in like huge
engagement things what type of stuff are
you going to talk about on your podcast
um yeah because i know it's coming out
it's out
and it's called uh it's the same as the
documentary this is paris
uh and what is to tell me about that
what and and what inspired you to get
into it and because there are so many
[ __ ] podcasts everyone's got a
podcast
um i just thought it was but i actually
never had listened to a podcast before
the pandemic hit and then i started them
enjoying them and then um my team
was in contact with i heart radio and
now i have my own podcasting company so
it's not just my podcast it's it's
called london audio and i
partnered with iheart and i am going to
be producing other ones we have like two
other ones coming out this year as well
under my umbrella so i just see it as
like an amazing business and an
extension of everything i do and i like
being in control and being able
to say what i want and not have to be
worried that an interviewer is going to
be annoying or rude i just feel like i'm
finally taking control of my story right
that must feel really empowering
especially for you because that that
persona that you had created seems to
have gotten i'm sure at one point it got
away from you you kind of you talk about
it um i i don't know the paparazzi what
they did to you and you know obviously
people now know what they did to
brittany what they do to people um
and i know people might think like oh
boohoo paparazzi but i've seen i've
witnessed that and it's [ __ ] sucks
what it does to people
yeah it's it's gotten out of control but
i think now with social media when
you know celebrities are getting their
photos and videos out before it makes
their pictures worth a lot less because
they already have been photographed in
the outfit it's already posted and
magazines can use that for free if they
take it from instagram so i think it
really ruined their business with social
media um
oh i wonder that too all those you talk
about that all those outfits that you
wear
you say you you haven't been you
photograph if you're photographed in
them you don't wear them again
what what happens to those outfits where
do they go
i donate them to different charities or
auctions or save things for my daughter
one day or my cousins or my friends
little london yes yeah
um
that's still the plan to color london
yeah stuff okay um
if you ideally uh how would you want the
next 20 years of your life to compare
the previous 20 years like would you
want less attention a different kind of
attention it sounds like a different
kind of attention maybe
definitely now i'm really focused on my
activism work and what i've been doing i
just passed a law two weeks ago i went
back to utah so
everything that happened to me is now
illegal today so
wow
wow that's incredible how what did that
entail how did you how did you do that
how do you how does one get a law passed
well right when the film came out we
held a rally like a protest outside of
provo with hundreds of survivors from
around the world that came
and that got the attention of the
senator uh mckellen from utah and then
we started talking and then i went there
and i testified in front of everyone
and then the law was just passed so it's
good for you
that is amazing did you when you went
back to that school did you see anyone
that you recognized and how difficult
was that i mean i i imagine it was it
was very traumatic i know a lot of the
other survivors they show them in the
and they they were visibly shaken how
did you get through that and and
what did that feel like
it actually felt empowering to be out
there and let them know that we
are standing up for ourselves and
all the kids inside who are like looking
through the windows just to have them
see oh my god oh my god she's trying to
help us thank god
uh eight-year-olds right eight
nine-year-olds
wow
so so as a result of this law those
schools were all shut down schools it's
weird to call them schools
you know i know i hate that word school
because it's not
i know it's it's it's diminishes how
abusive you describe them as cuckoo's
nest one floor of the cuckoo's nest it
sounds more like that um
what if it was cuckoo's nest did you
have a nurse ratchet was that was there
a singular yeah there was you had that
person yes and she actually
just finally got fired in october of
this year
or to 2020 so she was still there and
she was bragging to all the kids who
would come in like i'm the one who broke
paris hilton and was like always talking
about me all the time
wow
using you
i bet um
well it's i really commend you for um
how you've used that trauma and used it
for good you used it obviously to help
so many more kids who won't have to go
through that
is there a part of you that is
grateful to that struggle i mean you're
now doing so much with it it's shaped
you
um it's led to so many things in your
life good and bad
is there a part of you that that you
know thinks well without that i i may
have just gone down some
sanitary kind of
benign path
yeah i believe that everything in life
does happen for a reason and maybe i
needed to go through that so that one
day you know god would give me this
platform where i could make a difference
so it would not happen to other children
or you know other girls and i don't know
just kind of being that person who has
to go through something so that it
doesn't have to happen again to someone
else
[Music]
[Music]
we don't have much time and i have like
a like a lightning round uh question but
oh here this is what it is pods what is
pods
it's like an it's like a podcast
platform
yes um it's something that i invested in
it basically will take a podcast and
like take the best parts and it has this
out this ai which knows and
kind of like is like the cliff notes of
it it's very interesting you put your
podcast in there and it will literally
like
calculate it and like get it out into
like these little bite-sized
podcasts
how does it know what the best parts are
this this ai nowadays is smarter than
most people oh good lord that's so scary
i mean it's cool it's really it's cool
and scary
um and then you have you launched uh
silvington i love this name sylvington
uh oh silvington slivington
and it's my words living into slivington
what's living mean
living is a word that i invented
in the dictionary now and it means slain
and living your best life
slay and living your best living oh man
i'm so behind i i just heard them i had
to ask somebody what loki you know when
people say like oh that was low-key
funny
yeah how did you do
how would you i keep hearing i'm so old
um what are there words that you're
learning that you're like wait what does
that mean like um i know lit lit and
savage what are some new ones
there's so many new ones some words i'm
just like what oh yeah
yeah
slimming well that's new to me slipping
i mean that's hot was i know do you
still say that is that part of the
characters though
i love it
that's hot loves it he loves it
yes that is that's hot where did that
come from do you remember
um just back in the day my sister would
say it sometimes then i started saying
it because you know if you're with
someone all the time you pick up what
they say and then as a word is amazing
like i need to trademark it
has she ever been like wait a minute
[ __ ] you that that was my thing yeah we
talked about it once
you always copy me
it's sweet though you guys she seems to
really yeah i mean
she seems to really look out for you um
well okay lightning round here we go uh
what oh
so curious about this what is your most
commonly used emoji
your go-to i'm going to punctuate a
sentence with this
the heart eyes
mm-hmm
the blonde princess because it's me
oh
yeah
that's true okay that makes sense and
the heart eyes is so it's useful
you can use it for um if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why
i play ice hockey because i was on the
ice hockey team in high school
huh no kidding
uh you so you still skate you can you're
a good skater yeah i was a figure skater
when i was little as well so oh wow
wow is that some of your parents you
enjoyed doing it or was like
i played the violin when i was a kid my
parents kind of made me
i i played the violin too which i hated
like that
hated the violin don't you wish though
you had kept you still played i wish
sometimes i'm like i wish i could play i
know it is pretty cool now as an adult
looking at it but when you're little
you're just like this sucks i know i
want to play the guitar or something
cool drums
also the violin is like if you play it
well it's beautiful but it's so hard to
play well and anything less than playing
it really well is sounds
horrifying
um
uh if you could have
oh also do you ever have to watch what
you talk about i i know you you do so
much branding um most of your own stuff
do you ever have to like watch
what you're drinking publicly you know
in case you get photographed doing
something or
eating um
is that on your mind
not really oh okay
all right well i'm glad i like
supporting everybody you know
uh-huh well you're supporting life is
short podcast thanks for doing that
um if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life you're like
desert island snack food
do you smoke are you stupid to get
stoned
no
amazing
um either do i
uh
what would your uh i'm kidding what
would your snack food be
cotton candy
oh really i love it
and you can eat it like that like
popcorn like you're watching i don't
watch it that much but if i'm just i
that's the first thing i thought of the
top of my head like i love having candy
no kidding all right um what is your
favorite movie sequel of all time
my favorite super cool um
i usually like the first ones better i'm
trying to even think yeah
they're usually better
uh well while you're thinking it's not
that's not an important one like these
other ones are
what's your what's your what's your
go-to karaoke song
stars are blind by me
i almost said who's me
uh you have done that you've you've sent
your own karaoke song yeah that and
betty davis eyes by
the best yeah uh
the vinyls who sings that buddy davis
eyes uh don't tell me
kim barnes barnes
kim carnes
okay
uh [ __ ] that's a great song have you
been i haven't been in so long are you
going out of the house now are you
venturing out
yeah
yeah not like not much but um right i'm
vaccinated so yeah
nice
well done
you're very lucky uh i got my first the
other day and i it really knocked me out
they just after the first one
did you have a thing after the second
one did you get like
just tired my arm only hurt but that's
about it but it hurts everyone
differently it's weird yeah yeah um
if you who was your first celebrity
crush
luke perry
ah yeah oh my god god i just remembered
he
i can't believe he passed out man all
right
um that is so weird i know because i
just think of him as like that
good looking younger you know it's crazy
um
if you had to get a tattoo i know you
have tattoos um
you don't
you don't have any tattoos no
hey
neither do i like that um
have you ever thought that i don't know
why that's surprising to me have you
ever thought about getting one and would
you ever get one i've actually went with
my friends before like i'll always come
up with an idea like what's all going to
tattoo and we'll go to the place and
like i'll like pick it out or draw it
and then everyone will get it and then
i'm like looking at it i'm like actually
i don't really like how it looks what
you've made people get tattoos well it's
like all of our idea
yeah together and i just don't get it
because i'm the type that will get sick
of it right
right i would too that's why i haven't
gotten one i can't commit to well maybe
this relates to my relationship stuff
too um
committing to something that long
scary um
what would you get though i mean if you
had to
but the spores too
yeah
yeah i mean not by me i wouldn't for if
you were forced to buy i don't know who
would who does have that kind of power
over you your sister maybe
probably yeah yeah i think i would get
if i had to get something i would get
like
tinkerbell the fairy like the little
tiny one like right not tinkerbell the
accountant
no yeah it was like watching tinkerbell
so i didn't walk oh yeah
paris was that the dog that you had on
the simple life yeah
yeah yeah
you know who loves chihuahua's little
chihuahuas like you do is uh mickey
rourke did you know that
have you talked to him about that yes he
loves zwallahs like his babies
yes like he gets really emotional about
them and
yeah um if
if you had to uh what's your favorite
fruit
pomegranate
oh yeah hey do you know about the seek
you know about the spoon and the water
trick no
okay well and you're gonna be really
happy you did this podcast
you uh take a bowl of water
and cut the quarter it or cut it in half
it's easier if you quarter it and take a
spoon the back of a spoon and
knock the seeds out and when you can't
get out
put put the whole thing in the water and
just start kind of
unseating it in the water so all the
white crap
floats the top and all the seeds go to
the bottom so all the things you have to
like spit out are gone
gone it's not gone but they go but they
go to the top all the white you know
that like chuff like the stuff in
between
it all floats to the top and you just
scoop it out
and strain the seeds
i'm so happy i did this podcast yeah
well
you're welcome um
who uh who would you want to play you in
your biopic in the paris hilton story
directed by alexandra dean
everyone always asks me that and i have
no idea because i don't know if anyone
could give me justice so i would
i'll do it
okay all right that makes sense well you
are an actress uh who's your favorite
simpsons character
um
bart i think homer's like funniest but i
just think bart is a badass
you know what's funny you your voice i
bet you could do a good bart impression
it's not that far off
thanks i don't mean that as an insult
hey taliban got dude it's you have a i
just heard him um
i think i know the answer to this but
dogs are cats do you prefer dogs
dogs and you would set dogs your
favorite animals but um in terms of the
exotic animals you have what's one that
people might be surprised to learn like
oh a such and such like a giant
millipede really makes a good pet
well one
thing i have to say is teacup pigs do
not exist
do not be tricked into that because i
was tricked into it and lied and said it
they only get five pounds and i just
they gonna sleep in bed with me and that
was so obsessed and then
all of a sudden she was like 200 pounds
i just
i just pictured you spooning like a big
oinky
pig um
okay that's good advocacy to be doing in
addition to the other stuff you're doing
teacup
teacup pigs don't exist aren't those vet
what about vietnamese the pot belly pigs
those those all they all get huge
oh okay people get tricked because on
instagram they have like these cute
little tiny pigs and they lie and
pretend they'll only be
you know 5-10 pounds but that's just not
happening
and so then what do you do with
something like that once it gets it
becomes a huge porker
so i sent them to my ranch just to like
okay a little room free on the farm and
enjoy life
but a lot of people can't do that so
like
you know
god knows where those pigs end up and
that's what's so sad about it because
people don't realize how big they get
yeah yeah well they do that with a lot
of um
yeah uh they do with turtles a lot
uh ready to sliders um
anyway uh that's cool you have a ranch
where is the ranch
it's
like right in between nevada and
i don't know what it's called it's like
its own state basically huh okay it's
cool you have your own state it's even
cooler than having a ranch uh what be
the beatles do you prefer the beatles or
the rolling stones
the wrong stones
ah have you seen them you've seen them
yeah
yeah
uh in terms of those music festivals uh
which is your favorite to go to do you
still go to coachella
i love coachella but my favorite is
burning man
oh no kidding do you
bring art do you bring stuff to burn
i just go and enjoy it
nine days it's
amazing it's my favorite world paris i
have one i want to recommend to you you
might really enjoy it's in marfa texas
it's every september it's called el
cosmica or trans-picos
the trans-picos music festival it's a
lot it's a little bit more country-ish
but um
it's a beautiful place it's uh
you stay in an airstream trailer and the
sky is amazing anyway um
seinfeld or friends do you prefer
friends uh ketchup or mustard
ketchup and uh what are two adjectives
that you would want people to use to
describe you
after you've you've left the earth
when you've gone back up to where you're
from
brilliant and kind well you've been very
kind with your time and i think you're
brilliant uh i do i
i just was so
blown away by that documentary and um
all the work you're doing
uh to raise awareness so uh thank you
thanks for talking about it and and
there's something else um
i just want to make sure i plug all your
you have too many things going on
usually it's just like oh you have a new
movie coming out and there's one thing
um
did we talk about everything i want to
make oh this is parallel we talked about
the documentary what else what else do
you have
so many things
i know well where do we begin um well
you talk about it on instagram
right you do all of that
yeah well um we'll try my first nft
collection which is exciting oh yeah
yeah now tell me about what is an nf2
what does that mean i'm so dumb i it's a
it's it's like a digital
art piece that you can you can own
digitally what the hell is going on it's
a non-fungible token so basically a
digital art piece or it could be music
or a collectible or
experience and it's all linked on the
blockchain so it's it's pretty uh
fascinating i i describe it on
perisilton.com like i'm really going to
it
so if you really want to i wrote
okay nft so you can buy art i mean you
can own the original
huh um
okay that's so cool nft and somebody
that you were at that provo place with
described you as being like a brilliant
brilliant when it came to like
describing economics um
were you always like a really good math
student was that something that always
interested you numbers and math
i didn't really love math class
[Laughter]
um well you have a real head for this
thing and um
yeah i'm just really happy to have
gotten to talk to you about it all it's
really enlightening i don't know so they
could talk to you again it's been
forever it's been a long time yeah and
it's good to talk to you i i uh
you know this was really nice um so
thanks for doing it
thank you thanks paris you're very sweet
that was really nice have a great day
babe
you too
[Music]
well
that just happened that happened
that's is that her uh
her
yeah fake voice or her real voice her
fake voice is kind of like it's like
that
that's how that happened that was hot
that's hot that's hot there's like a
detachment her fake voice is like
there's kind of like doesn't really care
about anything can you say that's hot in
a way um in like a really casual oh
that's a good challenge um
ah that's hot
no but you have to say it in some
context okay um like say uh not about
like something literally hot like no no
yeah like you see an a really cool car
like uh like an audi r8 or something
that's so funny i was just talking about
the audi all right how hot that is
how hot that is
that's a hot car uh okay well let me try
okay
um until i do it poorly uh okay so god i
saw the uh i saw this audi r8 the other
day
i can't do it that was hot it was hot
what was hot the audi all right it was
what it was hot
hot he has a hot car that's the hot
wheels
had some hot wheels on that car uh it's
hard oh my god look at that car over
there yeah what about it it's so hot
damn now how about sliving can you use
that i never heard that
i didn't know i also didn't know she um
she coined
uh loves it
i don't know that was hers oh i did yeah
you did yeah that was because i thought
that was um
you know i thought that was perez hilton
not paris yeah i thought that was perez
i just realized how weird that is that
that perez hilton has named himself
after her basically it is weird i but i
think it's i mean obviously it's because
um
he his whole
game was celebrity yeah kind of and she
was the biggest
the biggest
in heaven that's crazy perez hilton i i
that guy i'm glad he got his come up and
he did kind of right
definitely but what does he do now is he
like uh i think he just does like a tame
version of what he used to do oh you
know like like a respectful version oh
he used to draw like sexual stuff awful
yeah yeah
yeah there was a whole like bully
culture around people like paris hilton
i remember and and i had never
considered
i mean she really like this documentary
really did it as you could probably hear
but it really humanized her and talking
to her did too i mean it was interesting
talking to her because it was i had seen
her yeah i know the few times we nearly
rose to acquaintance level when we were
hanging out that summer but
even then it was like you know she was
throwing these parties so it wasn't like
we had time to really connect with one
another come over to our group
and she'd
you know we'd
see each other for a little bit but it
wasn't like
i don't know i she had never been
humanized to me i guess is the best way
to say it yeah
she's always like a figure
well that's what makes it that much more
fascinating that she had this character
that
she played that's like very
specific here which is
interesting that
she
gained so much popularity doing that
character i know and she has a legion of
fans i know like an army of fans that
she's
many of whom she's friends with and
they're not called hilton heads that i
was
i was very proud of that
of you for that joke that was really
funny thank you um
but it's she didn't i don't think she no
but who cares yeah uh
but it's weird to me that um
she got all these fans all this
notoriety all this you know fame and
fortune and everything
doing this character fame and fashion
and everything that goes with this
[Laughter]
and now she
seems to really
resent that i know
like
it's
weird
she has with that character is
com must be really complicated and with
fame as a thing as a beast with
celebrity as a as as
but as i mean she kind of helped create
that celebrity culture the paparazzi
that's what was so surprising about her
in the documentary the guy that's like i
guess one of her like managers or
something he's in her orbit um orbit uh
he
he he profited off of her for years he
was he started that
i forget the name of it uh that's
paparazzi
agency
and like their number one
uh target
i'm a lawyer oh yeah god those people
the what does it call it tmz emcee yeah
it's funny when you told her that you
have
a handful of turtles and she didn't
react to it
i also like she i i'm not to be like
proud of my job but like uh the
tinkerbell the fairy that was very funny
i've never heard anyone say tinkerbell
the fairy neither it's always implied
that it's a fairy that's
tinkerbell the accountant
tinkerbell the firefighter yeah
tinkerbell the
high school english teacher
it's funny to imagine other tinkerbells
i wonder if anyone's named
tinkerbell
definitely definitely right yeah i'm
sure i mean people are named crazy
things i bet there's
if i had to guess i would say i mean
obviously i have no idea but if i had to
guess with like 10 tinker bells in the
world oh i would say more really yeah i
would say
ah 300
300 tinker bells i bet
like it's funny not 300 300 now feels
like a lot a lot i mean you'd have to
i've never met one but i'm always
meeting new names people with new names
yeah but tinkerbell isn't a new name
it's it's a it's a character yeah it's
true but maybe there's not three are
there garfield is anyone named garfield
i'm sure
yeah yeah od yeah odibe
do you think more people named garfield
are named after the cartoon or the
president oh the cartoon really for sure
i i bet back in it obviously i wonder if
that's depressing i wonder if that's
depressing to garfield the president i
bet there's a couple tinker bells and
garfields she talked about having a
doggy mansion that she said really
casually
and i realized that her dogs
live
much better than i do
yeah yeah you know worked up four dogs
no for any creature no no no a doggy
mansion
yeah i guarantee you that thing is
beautiful i'm sure but like what do dogs
really need to be happy i'm not saying
they need the mansion i'm just saying
they but humans can
humans could benefit more from like uh
you know opulent [ __ ] surroundings
i think i mean you'd get i think as a i
don't think you'd be a good writer so
you're saying that dog wouldn't
appreciate no the the opulence yeah i
bet the dog would just that i would
really appreciate the opulence i don't
like that stuff anyway exactly
i i really appreciate how she she saves
a lot of animals she's she does a lot of
advocacy on behalf of rescues um you and
paris have a lot in common it wasn't
that funny i know you've a lot in common
no violin violin animals yeah
animals what else you both like uh
there's something that really made me
laugh that uh oh
i'm not crazy about cotton candy
although i both like pomegranates yup
yeah that's right
that's right do you think she'll try my
pomegranate trick
uh
no no you don't not because you think
she has someone not because she doesn't
believe you but i think she probably
gets pomegranate already yeah i thought
about that yeah i can't bring myself to
buy those it's just too expensive it's
like crazy
pomegranates well especially now that
you know this trick i know and it's kind
of fun i've never tried this trick i'd
like to oh you'd like it a lot because
you like a meticulous like you know two
dots popping bubbles stuff like that you
like doing little meticulous oh [ __ ]
sure too you don't have to ruin it by
saying ocd things oh sorry no no that's
not why is that ruining
are you it
really fast
yeah you're a little juiced up i just
had a coffee you're drinking coffee
right now yeah but i just had it i'm
still having it
um
yeah but you do have a lot in common
yeah it's
nice turtles she's something crazy about
turtles i don't think reptiles
she's i she i i i always amazed me that
she liked that snake that she had a
snake you're both world-renowned djs
that's true well that's true
yeah we both dated remember when she
dated paris lazis
yeah he was an heir he was in there as
well yeah
and then another wasn't there another
surprise that didn't work out they'd so
both named paris both heirs i wonder how
much mileage they got out of that
i like that her karaoke song is her own
song well you know what that reminded me
of
i once saw at uh sing sing i think
shout out to sing sing i hope they're
still open my god is that place fun
karaoke bar karaoke bar yeah i shouldn't
yeah contextualized
a prison no right right
you know what a good name for another
good name for a karaoke place i just
thought of is uh sang quentin
you know
sing sing and sing anyway sing sing um
you know what i wrote because they have
this is such a braggy story at sing-sing
at the karaoke bar because they have you
they they've had asked me to sign a
thing
what do you think i wrote that sing-sing
i bet you said something like
i had a good good time time oh oh yeah i
did i said i sang sang my heart heart
out yeah see
you're so predictable yeah but i i once
saw lindsay lohan was there hopefully
future guests yes lindsay i hope we're
trying we're
i'm sure she's listening texting about
i'm sure she is
we i came close we were texting she's
like i'm down what day and then i didn't
hear back anyway lindsay uh was uh is an
old friend old acquaintance i guess um
and
she i walked into the room she said come
down we're down in the downstairs
singing room and i when i walked in she
was with a couple friends she was
singing her song
well that was cool like paris yeah
there's some crosstalk over there are
they friends they were friends really
good friends i think they had some i
remember there was always like drama
with that
group i wonder if they're still friends
i don't know i wonder well i should have
asked paris i'm surprised you didn't
that's actually a pretty big in you had
i was like conversational that's true
i'm surprised you didn't use it they
were good friends i think definitely
yeah
yeah i think all of those she may not
have wanted to rehash a
former friendship that's true if there
was some big falling out falling out
yeah she wants a promoter podcast so it
feels her new podcast empire oh right
right i like how she doesn't just start
a podcast she starts
it's like if she like opened up a little
like ice cream shop she'd have like a
whole ice cream chain
god it'd be fun to start an ice cream
she's also into digital currency
i don't get that at all you don't both
have to not get digital currency i that
has been explained to me by really smart
people i know so many times and i i at
this point i'm confident that i'll never
understand it it's i like my brain just
won't wrap around it after we talked i
read i tried to like read i tried to
familiarize myself with it but it was
like um
and i read about how it's not good for
the environment a lot of people say it's
like it takes up a lot of energy
um but i couldn't understand how or why
like the servers that are required for
it
um
i don't know i i my brain just doesn't
it's incapable of certain things
i i'm just not smart enough maybe that's
what it is did i just say that in a high
flute and way highfalutin
kind of what's the thing that pause said
that um
to his brother
oh yeah does it
shorties does anybody has anybody heard
this expression
well so-and-so is in fine fettle today
and fine federal is that a um
like a very archaic saying
i think it is you know i think the only
reason i know it is recently is because
of our
i don't know what to call them paw but i
almost said our father yeah
let's read a letter okay
um i didn't print it out in our printer
but i'm going to hand you my phone
because miesha just sent me this okay
my finger oh yeah justin uh slammed his
door slammed his door slammed his finger
in his door well i did slam the door but
it's really bulbous it looks like a
cartoon finger it does like it does like
wow wow it's like pulsating you should
put that in ice well i have a little ice
water yeah i have a little who cares oh
that's not going to do it that's what
you're using it's ice it's frozen
i think you need something more hardcore
this is like
this is one of those packs you need like
ice water what would paris do
she um
she write about she has a person for
that do you think yeah she has a team of
people she is on hand in case she slams
her finger in a door who to take care of
her she's a team of medics uh god i wish
i did
um okay well let's get through this and
then um ice your finger okay
from caroline or carolyn how do you
spell it i think it's caroline ca it's
sweet caroline
it's spelled the same as sweet caroline
i think it could be pronounced either
way though man that's annoying caroline
in the city oh yeah yeah caroline jones
subject howdy and then hi guys i've just
finished listening to your nick frost
chat and i loved him so much in spaced
i think i've watched all episodes of
that series about three times over it is
really good daisy in the program is just
amazing i'm writing from a little room
in my house that i work in doing graphic
design i live not too far from london in
the uk and have my favorite podcast that
i listen to for company each day and
yours is up there for me how nice
i love your brother leave chats and your
giggles my fave episode of yours so far
as the vince vaughn one that i have
revisited numerous times thank you
carolyn
anywho
that's the cherry anyhoo anything
for getting people to do that do you
think that's what she meant i think so
she spells it with a lot of ohs anywho
any who
maybe not maybe i'm any who
it's cold and blustery here as i look
out to my garden with kids toys strewn
across the grass so it's very dickensian
the grass yes i know the moors
it's a comfort it's a comfort to listen
to you and i hope she i maybe i
shouldn't be doing the accent now
because it's nice it's sort of
comforting it's a comfort it's a comfort
to listen to you and i just wanted to
say thanks and hi
keep doing it and i look forward to the
next one x
is x just a kiss i think so
p.s
would you rather live in a oh yes would
you rather live in a warm bath that kept
getting topped off with fresh hot water
or your skin was protected with an
emollient so it wouldn't perish and your
skin was protected with ammonia so it
wouldn't perish
god i love the way british people speak
right or live in a forever moving
treadmill that's great
holy [ __ ] okay would you rather live in
a warm bath that kept getting topped off
and your skin
well in the bath you wouldn't be able to
really interact with people the second
one is on a treadmill so you're
constantly constantly walking
you imagine how big your legs would be
uh do you think they would just keep
getting bigger
i don't know i mean there's got to be a
way to
protect
the same way that there's an emollient
to protect your skin in the bubble bath
you know i don't really see an argument
for the treadmill oh really yeah do you
i do because you are um
you you're at least outside you're able
to it might be easier to interact with
people you think well in a bath they
don't have to come to you they'd have to
come to you in a trial that's a
treadmill too that's true
a forever moving treadmill um
and wouldn't it be exhausting
yeah but counterpoint the bath wouldn't
you just get so
lethargic and depressed in a bath for
yeah treadmill
is flowing and that's true but i think
that's true you'd get
ah
that's tough
they both sound awful don't it yeah it's
for a for a day
i would definitely pick the bath that's
because it sounded like yeah the idea of
having nice hot water i know um
constantly being topped off that sounds
amazing i was shooting nights uh in
fayetteville and it was so nice to come
back to i started taking baths because
you know you go through these like
really
do you say baths or baths oh i say baths
you do but it's probably bad i i'm sure
carolyn would say
baths
baths
would you rather live in a warm bath
that kept getting topped off with fresh
hot water
um that's tough i i think i choose the
tread also the treadmill though i'm
sleeping well how do you oh my god well
if you sleep in the bath you drown not
necessarily you just keep your head out
of here yeah
i'm just picturing you in a bad having
to come to you
you'd have to come to me on a treadmill
and i wouldn't be able to focus on the
conversation if i was out of breath and
i uh
i guess i picked the path yeah those are
tough but good ones carolyn you know
what you know what um if it was a bath
or just running not on a treadmill like
jogging
um
around like forrest gump uh that'd be
funny i think i would pick the jogging
oh me too for sure
because then you'd see things didn't we
have one similar to that like um
we had one where it was it was skipping
if you were always skip you always had
to be skipping or something else or or
um trotting
no trotting skipping or crab walking
trotting what's trotting
trotting like you know have you ever
imitated a horse yeah that's that's good
that's a skip isn't it
no i think script's different how would
you how's trump i i can't show you here
because this room is too small sure but
it's like it it's a different rhythm
we're skipping yeah
oh yeah trotting's probably easier yeah
and less goofy yeah still goofy i'm
picturing you trotting carolyn jones
designs giving her company a shout out
wonder what she does oh she's a graphic
designer yeah okay
huh
see the treadmill thing is
that's something depressing about that
it's like you're in a hamster wheel or
something i know but if you're running
outside and you get to interact with
people different story different story
sleeping would still be an issue
you'd be impossible let's wrap it up i
think okay you know what i was going to
do is just do another little just to
bring it full circle september 17th lady
of the manor comes out yes and if you
would like to write in to the show like
caroline did or carolyn
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com and thank you so much for
listening it was hot i think that
episode was hot it was hot it was fire
it was lit
a slave and i hope this week you all
continue to slip you know paris hilton
is slave a verb i don't know it's a good
question i think it is this is what i'll
say about paris hilton there is
no one like her that is true she is a
very unique she is yeah she really is
there's no one like her that's why that
question was really good that you wrote
that was like how would you how would
she describe herself to an alien and
when she kind of liked her response i
did too it like kind of made sense she's
and she's like i'm an alien she might be
she's definitely the closest to alien
we've had on the show well i think
aliens you've been seeing all this about
ufos and stuff isn't that the craziest
thing that during the year of the
pandemic that's how crazy last year was
that the government actually came out
and said oh yeah ufos exist there are
ufos and it wasn't that big of a story
what's the big stop i know it's nuts not
so like aliens exist there are aliens
okay so someone's flying those things
yeah and if paris and if they've been
living among us
uh
and paris hilton was one of them i
wouldn't be surprised
you know i wouldn't either
so um
i thought it was interesting talking to
her and i wish her luck with all in all
of her endeavors too many to name really
she has too many endeavors yes um but
check out her podcast empire check out
hopefully one of those podcasts you'll
be in too um and we thank her for doing
ours and we thought it was it was uh hot
it was hot so uh thank you for listening
as well and thanks to carolyn and thanks
for letting us um really indulge
ourselves yeah and overly promoting our
most indulgent uh i promise this is the
last time we're gonna talk about it
that's right this is the last time we're
gonna be so shameless about it yeah
that's true uh yeah well hopefully
hopefully just imagine you know it's
exciting for us because it's our first
one and we really like it so uh
september 17th later
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short it's hosted by me justin
long co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan the monaco senior producer is
michelle
audio engineer is the one and only
sergio enriquez by the way i'm sure
there are other sergio enriquez's i
didn't mean to uh offend anybody do you
think there's more sergio enriquez's
than tinkerbells yes executive producer
is marshall louis for wondering
[Music]
before i like got near him yeah
i probably would i try to remember when
i first laid eyes
yeah i was probably like cute yeah that
would be my instinct sure i used to
think he was cute in your like instagram
pictures before i met him
i mean false advertising totally false
but but but you know um i'm also i also
have a prejudice against so if i just
saw him in a picture i
i've i'm kind of racist against
pomeranians
like
i like
yeah yeah so i went into me knowing
tanner
tanner's only solidified he's
is that like a cute now oh tanner now
had no he he had a ch he i'm saying like
there were two strikes against him
because i have a prejudice against
and he did and and he did such a
disservice to i don't it's not like i
like dogs less i still love dogs as much
as i used to but i like pomeranians even
less than i did and he he even made that
breed which i'm embarrassed about my
racism toward he made them
less likable
that's what a [ __ ] was i love their
friends
oh friends
uh samson samson didn't help
but wasn't tanner cuter than samson like
please no no